salut à tous j'ai une excellente
nouvelle à partir d'aujourd'hui et
toutes les semaines on va faire une
vidéo pour évaluer votre chaîne on va
regarder ce qui va ce qui ne va pas
quels sont les points à améliorer pour
vous permettre d'avoir une chaîne
beaucoup plus complète bien meilleur et
que nous permettront enfin de réussir
sur youtube de plus en plus de chaînes
par jour sur youtube et c'est vrai qu'il
est extrêmement difficile d'y réussir
je partage avec vous toute mais l'astuce
et les meilleures techniques pour gagner
des vues les convertir en harnais et
enfin réussir sur youtube à ce qu'elle
voit ma chaîne activer la cloche pour ne
manquer aucune vidéo une fois par
semaine vous serez une vidéo
d'évaluation de votre chaîne youtube on
va regarder ensemble ce qui va ce qui ne
va pas pour la personne qui sera
sélectionné c'est intéressant pour
énormément de points on va regarder si
la stratégie est la bonne si la manière
est bien fait si elle pas bien fait
comment l'améliorer
quels sont les points qu'on peut
actionner rapidement pour régner
désabonner début est ce qu'on peut
améliorer l'existant si oui comment
globalement va regarder si la stratégie
est bonne et comment l'améliorer
pourquoi faire à partir maintenant des
évaluations de vidéos tout simplement
voit déjà pour la personne qui sont
sélectionnés se donnera tout de suite
les points pour améliorer sa chaîne et
pour voir comment aller dans le dans la
bonne direction si toutefois il n'y
arrive pas on se fait avant la vidéo
l'intérêt c'est une étude de cas
concrètes
on va regarder directement sur une
chaîne on va prendre le temps de
regarder qu'est ce qui marche
qu'est ce qui ne marche pas et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire c'est si vous voulez
une façon de mettre en pratique les
différents conseils qui sont plutôt
théorique que je donne dans mes autres
vidéos ça va vraiment vous apporter des
éléments de réponse et vous aider à
progresser directement sur votre chaîne
youtube pour vous inscrire c'est
extrêmement facile je vous ai mis un
lien ici vous pouvez aussi retrouver
dans la description en dessous pour
pouvoir vous abonner il suffit de
marquer votre nom prénom pour savoir à
qui je parle je donnerais pas retenu
rassurez vous dans la vidéo vous donner
aussi la thématique de votre chaîne vous
me donnez à l'adresse de votre chaîne
bien évidemment votre email si j'ai
besoin de vous écrire et vous validez à
la suite de ça je vais sélectionner une
chaîne par semaine ceux-ci trouver la
chaîne qui est la plus représentative
pour tout le monde alors je vais pas
forcément pour centrer sur les chaînes
qui seront les mieux réussies parce que
l'idée justement se trouvait d'échelle
qui ont des
l'erreur et des points d'amélioration
sur lesquels on peut travailler et qui
vont servir vraiment à illustrer la
théorie donc envoyé moi rochelle n'ayez
pas peur on va regarder ça ensemble et
je suis comme ça que ça vous permettra
de progresser et de gagner des vues des
abonnés et de réussir sur youtube merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et ce n'est
pas la partager autour de vous si vous
connaissez d'autres amis youtuber ça
peut aussi les aider et les intéressés
merci beaucoup à bientôt et quant à moi
je donne rendez vous très très
rapidement pour une prochaine vidéo
salut